um uh what you probably know but the
Simon's Institute is the world's leading
venue for collaborative research and
theoretical computer science uh
established by a generous Grant from the
Simon's foundation in 2012 who continues
to generously support us
and uh the primary aim of our semester
programs is to um
is to explore the use of algorithmic
thinking in in computer science in a
decent fields and to study the laws of
computation itself and so I'm very
excited to in uh welcome you today to
this workshop on on dynamic graphs and
algorithms which is one of the you know
key ingredients in many of these recent
exciting breakthroughs on graph
algorithms
uh I want to cover a few logistics for
the coming week so food is provided in
the breaks right outside lunch is not
provided and you're welcome to go
outside and explore the interesting
restaurants nearby for lunch there are
some lockers on the other side of the
building uh where you can leave your
stuff when you go out for lunch that's
that's quite convenient uh and and we do
ask that you don't bring food back in
here
um uh all the talks are recorded our
videographer Omid Farr is sitting over
there he'll help you with any uh
problems that may arise
and uh uh I if I do invite anyone who's
active on Twitter who wants to tweet
about this to go ahead and do so but if
you do so please uh please tag us and
we'll be sure to retweet uh hear your
Tweet
and I want to give a special thanks to
uh Ashley Hassan and Elizabeth un for uh
managing all of the logistics of this
Workshop uh so let's let's give them a
hand
[Applause]
and uh let me hand over to Monica now
oh I'm Monica hensinger I'm one of the
organizers of This research program and
also one of the organizers of this
Workshop I want to welcome you all thank
you for coming it's a great pleasure to
have you all here and I'm looking
forward to an exciting week of talks and
conversations
just those a few administrative things
so there will be coffee every morning at
nine we will only start the talks at 9
30 they're either four or five talks
except for Friday there are only three
talks usually the talks end at four so
you still have time to discuss with
other people except for Friday where we
end at noon already so in case you have
to catch a flight also today there's a
wine and cheese reception afterwards
well it used to be wine and cheese let's
see whether it's still wine and cheese
Simons didn't say so it's a surprise
reception at four o'clock from four to
five this evening and I hope you will be
around
um otherwise of course feel free to wear
your mask to protect yourself you're not
required but of course feel free to I
will actually also put it all in a
second thank you and so today we'll
actually all organ be organized and
managed by Julian Chun so I will hand it
over to Julian
yeah
all right uh thanks a lot Monica so
we're going to be starting off with
lightning talks for an hour
um thank you all to those thank you to
those who submitted slides
um and since these are going to be short
talks uh you can just come up here and
and use the microphone we're going to be
playing through the slides in
alphabetical order by last name
um and then if there's time in at the
end for those of you who didn't submit a
slide if you want to say a few words
um you're welcome to come up as well
um okay so SRI Tron
foreign
made these slides for like 50 seconds
and then I learned I have like three
minutes so I'll try to go through it
slower
uh yes so I'm switching I'm at the
University of Vienna I'm advised by
Monica henzinger
uh so these are not ordered by interest
they are ordered by length of the words
so I'm interested in Dynamic graph
algorithms hierarchical clustering so in
Dynamic graph algorithms I had a project
on low bounds for dynamic algorithms on
expanders
uh I'm currently working on some
hierarchical clustering projects I had a
differential privacy project again
Dynamic uh showing some Dynamic data
structures are private
and I have a project with gramos Monica
and sushant on Flow algorithms where we
showed oblivious routing with electrical
flows we're doing some stuff there as
well and so this is generally my
research stuff if you want to talk to me
about things which are not research you
might find some books or something on my
website if you want to talk to me about
books so and then we can start talking
about research after that
that's me
hello uh I'm Otto and hike and I'm jet
lagged I'm also at the University of
Vienna super PhD students provide by
Monica as well
um I work on Dynamic graph algorithms
and dynamic graphs so subtle difference
Dynamic graph algorithms is why we are
all here
um so essentially Edge coloring be
matching shortest paths these kind of
problems which I guess you are all
familiar with
dynamic graphs is a bit different it's
more about graphs that evolve over time
and they can be highly Dynamic so
usually when you think in Dynamic graph
algorithm is just one Edge inserted one
Edge deleted this kind of stuff in
dynamic graphs it's maybe all the graph
changes all the time and you don't
really care about maintaining a solution
just ask other problems such as
broadcast for example when you have a
piece of information and you want to
spread it across the graph over time so
information spreading is the same radius
very similar and some other problems
like consensus and reliable broadcast
um yeah so this is what I do
research-wise uh a bit uh if we zoom out
a bit and if you want to talk about me
to me about something
um one of the questions I'm interested
in is of course climate change you all
know about this
um as computer scientists as researchers
as well in general what can we do
um yeah so if you have ideas if you want
to talk about this I will be happy to
talk to you about this
and I think it's Sebastian afterwards
[Applause]
my name is Sebastian Foster I'm at the
University of Salzburg also Austria so
somehow this Workshop is started by
austrians are like people in Austria
um I mainly interested in Dynamic
algorithms that's why I'm here most
interested a bit in distributed
algorithms in particular in the
conscious model so if you'd like to talk
to me about that yeah feel free to talk
to me about that
um why I'm I'm where I'm here for is um
I'd like to more broadly discuss like
how does this field Dynamic graph
algorithms develop what are like the
real fundamental challenges I guess we
all know about this oblivious adaptive
adversary thing um are there other like
you know fundamental challenges barriers
um and the other thing is and I I think
that's already reflected in the program
a bit I'd like to learn more about like
how could Dynamic algorithms have an
impact in realities so that means how to
engineer them and how to maybe go a bit
more in
problems that maybe a larger Community
is interested in like graph mining
machine learning data science type of
things so if you would like to talk
about this yeah please talk to me about
it thank you
[Applause]
hello so you just saw me
I work at this wonderful place okay IST
Austria it's a research institute
government funded
um where there are PhD students but no
undergraduates and there's lots of great
people there and so if you're looking
for a postdoc I'm always looking for
excellent postdocs then send me mail
um I'm interested in data structures
especially Dynamic graph algorithms they
are upper and lower bounds combinatorial
algorithms again mostly graph algorithms
so recently I worked on minimum cut
static minimum cut problem and then
differential privacy and they are mostly
the dynamic setting which is called
differential privacy under continual
observation I give a talk about Dynamic
graph algorithms last week here at
diamonds is also on YouTube if you want
to watch it but there I also mentioned
that I think the direction where Dynamic
graph algorithms should move is more
into
becoming more varied meaning you look at
Dynamic graph algorithms with additional
properties for example external memory
Dynamic graph algorithms or massively
parallel Dynamic graph algorithms or
differential private Dynamic graph
algorithms or graph algorithm for small
space okay so these are the research
questions that I'm very interested in
currently thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
solving long-standing open problems
especially in the graph algorithms and
um so my research can largely be
characterized and you take two uh
techniques called preconditioning
locality which were the main topics of
my thesis
and in the past I've
um this I have studied problems such as
Global Min cut parallel shortest pad
Dynamic connectivity experience
composition in the future I like to
investigate
um mostly uh problems on directed graphs
for example direct hops their shortcuts
incremental cycle detection
which is also direct a graph problem
things like can we simplify the recent
Maxwell algorithm and also more
generally
um
are they better with graph
decompositions for the director graphs
thanks
[Applause]
good morning my name is John Owens
um welcome to Berkeley this is where I
live so I'm happy to see people flying
in from all over the place uh I work on
gpus I'm not a theorist I really like
coming to conferences like this because
there's have tons of interesting ideas
and are super interested in seeing them
uh be implemented in practice on
Parallel kinds of machines which is what
I know and so this has been a very good
sort of collaboration for me over my
career in talking to Julian what we
thought you might want to hear about I'm
going to talk about sort of the
realities of what it's like implementing
dynamic graphs on gpus and so I'll talk
a little bit our own work but also on
some of the other approaches and I think
one thing that comes out of this is what
an enormous Gap there is between theory
and practice and all the wonderful work
that you all are doing is still to be
realized at least in the GPU front and I
hope that means there will be
opportunities for future problem solving
so I'm speaking on Thursday I think and
I look forward to meeting and chatting
with many of you in the meantime
[Applause]
yeah Michael is not weird
foreign
student at Stanford University I'm very
fortunate to be advised by I'm in
Sovereign
I'm mostly interested in a theoretical
Foundation of large graph algorithms
from both algorithmic side and lower one
side this includes settings such as
sub-linear time algorithms local
computation algorithm and dynamic
algorithms and so both sub-linear
algorithm and local computation
algorithms has have applications in
Dynamic algorithms the last year best
paper at soda use the submarine time
algorithm for maximum matching to get a
and get the result for the get to break
the long-standing of a problem for
dynamic matching algorithm my main focus
is on maximum matching problem
if you're interested to know about one
of my Works Sohail one of my quarters is
going to present one of our results this
Friday
thank you
foreign
from MIT so I I work in both the theory
and practice of parallel Computing so in
terms of parallel algorithm design uh my
group enjoys designing algorithms have
nice theoretical guarantees in terms of
their work and their parallelism but
also Implement these algorithms and make
sure that they run efficiently on Modern
Hardware and on Modern data sets my
group's also interested in building
programming Frameworks to make it easier
for programmers to write fast parallel
code since parallel programming is
notoriously difficult to get right
um and we've been focusing a lot
recently on graph and spatial data
processing especially in the dynamic
settings so I'm looking at the batch
Dynamic setting where the updates to
your data set arrive in batches and you
want to officially maintain some
property of your data set but within
each batch you can actually use
parallelism to speed things up and we'll
actually be hearing a couple talks about
this throughout this Workshop
um and I'm also interested in concurrent
data structures especially ones that can
be used to make graph processing
efficient in the concurrent setting
foreign
[Applause]
I work on Matrix data structures so you
have like a matrix or a vector space
that changes over time you want to
maintain properties and it turns out
that you can use that inside like
Dynamic graph algorithms to maintain
things like shortest path or matching
and I also work on optimization
algorithms because you can use these
data structures to make them more
efficient
thanks
[Applause]
I'm Helen um I'm a postdoc also in
Berkeley lab so it's just up the hill
um
I finished my PhD a couple years ago at
MIT and I work on Parallel Computing
both in theory and in practice like data
structures a lot and
yeah and I also work on graph algorithms
and data structures for graphs thank you
hi I'm Chris I think I misunderstood the
assignment a little bit but okay um I'm
a first year student at UCSD my advisors
are Russell and payata and barnasaha and
I guess so my main interest in Dynamic
graph algorithms is algorithms of
prediction I guess I probably won't go
into details now
um but the main question is just can
algorithms its predictions help us solve
hard problems and I'm also pretty
interested in approximate shortest path
and other Dynamic problems and seeing so
there's I guess a lot of progress to the
shortest path of like static setting and
I want to see if maybe those
improvements can be extended to Dynamic
algorithms as well thanks
[Applause]
thank you
hello everyone my name isai
I'm a
Simon currently and previously I
graduated from alto University under the
supervision with uh
now I'm after Simon I will start a
postal position at Hebrew University uh
with ombre Weinstein and my latest
interest includes like combinatory
optimization on Fast algorithm on Cut
flow and network design problem in
particular I'm interested in like grab
connectivity problems and I have uh I
work a lot on like local cut problems
and also on like vertex connectivity
with some very recent results on the
voltage connectivity in poly lock
netflow there's a some sample of the the
result that I have and on the network
design problem I'm also interested in
like Fast LP solver how to solve LP very
fast in particular on the multiplicative
update like first order method and if
you are interested in how to kind of
accelerate the multiple keyboard update
algorithm uh then you can you should you
can check out the on Friday talk with
ombre talks and also I'm also interested
in the data structure in particular on
the dynamic tree like this play tree and
the dynamic optimality contexture I'm
really interested in working on their
contact and travel contexture and the
way that I'm interested in this is more
like on the
a stabbing connection between the
monetize analysis and the combinatorics
like extreme combinatorics thank you
[Applause]
hello my name is David
um I'm a PhD student at UIUC and I have
a bunch of different interests but my
main interests are in geometry and
graphs so I've done a lot of work on
geometric data structures with my
advisor Timothy Chan I've done some work
on bipartite matchings with Monica and
also some work on
data structures for data structures on
metroids and recently I've been working
on embedded planar graphs in the
massively parallel Computing model with
yujun Chung at the University of
Singapore so my interests are pretty
broad so I I guess there's a lot of
things I want to talk about with other
people and you're free to come to me
during the breaks and chat about
anything
thank you
okay so these were indeed lightning
talks we finished all of them in 18
minutes
um so uh since we have time
um what do people think about me just
passing the mic around and if you didn't
introduce yourself you can just say your
name where you're from and what you're
interested in
um and if you don't want to talk you can
pass the mic along
uh
sorry
yeah to the neighbor to uh yeah you can
just pass it to your neighbor when
you're done
okay thank you hi everyone my name is
Aaron sidford I'm a professor at oh I
have to stand hi everyone my name is
Aaron sidford I'm a professor at
Stanford I'm one of the organizers of
the Simon's program this uh fall my
interests are broadly in algorithms
optimization
um and yeah thanks
I'm Phillip Klein professor at Brown
University and uh visitor for the
semester and I'm interested in
algorithms graph algorithms data
structures and so on I thought these
talks were great so uh I'd love to talk
to several of the people just to learn
more about what they're doing
foreign
months and I'm interested in most areas
in TCS I guess
um so if you can cash me in one of the
brace fuel please feel free to do so
I'm young hello again
hi I'm uh from Tel Aviv University
and I'm also interested in algorithms
data structures approximation algorithms
same mainly for a constraint
satisfaction problems
mathematical games recreational
mathematics okay looking forward to
there is knowing many of you
hi so I made you in vlado from cnrs and
University of parisite I do research in
combinatorial optimization somewhere the
intersection between continuous
optimization and combinatorial
optimization and yep happy to chat with
you about any of these things
[Laughter]
hi I'm Tower and I'm an incoming PhD
student in Stanford and I'm interested
in graph algorithm and problem with a
combinatorial flavor
hi I'm jallo from Stanford I'm a second
year PhD and I'm interested in graph
algorithms and Game Theory
um I'm Simon or Simon meyerhans and I'm
a PhD student with Rasmus King and I'm
interested in graph algorithms both
static and dynamic
hi I'm Neil I'm a PhD student at USC my
interests are combinated with
optimization
approximation algorithms for graphs and
some other community structures and
recently getting started with data
structures and general graph algorithms
hi everyone I'm Shari Solomon I'm a
professor of associate professor of
Television University I'm interested in
bunch of things including graph
algorithm and static and dynamic
geometric distributed
and also results that are not
algorithmic and in particular discrete
geometry
and I think I'll stop
uh here and I'm looking forward to many
of the talks and uh to knowing uh many
of you
um should I test this
hey everyone I'm Savita I'm a senior
researcher at Microsoft research in
Redmond I work on algorithms for Big
Data including High dimensional geometry
streaming algorithms diversity
maximization fairness yeah glad to be
here
hi everyone I am Ali vacillian I'm a
research assistant professor at ttic I
work on algorithm for Big Data streaming
sub-linear LCA and also learning based
algorithm algorithmic prediction also on
a different topic I also work on
algorithmic fairness
hi I'm Veronica I'm a PhD student at
epfl uh broadly interested in graph
algorithms sublinear algorithms
yeah
hi I'm elipovate from Berlin University
and I will repeat everything that the
people you said I'm interested in the
emigra Fargo team sublingual team
sketching and so on
everyone my name is Omri Omri Weinstein
I'm a professor at the Hebrew University
and Columbia University
I'm interested like everyone here in
algorithms and uh
and optimization and most recently in uh
practical approximate matrix
multiplication algorithms for speeding
up deep neural networks so all GPU folks
here
feel free to give me a shout
hi everyone I'm Lee Chen Zhang I'm a PhD
student from MIT I'm interested in
sketching and the continuous
optimization algorithms and there are
applications to graph algorithms
hi my name is tejing I'm a fourth year
PhD student at MIT and I work on
algorithms and fine-grained complexity
hi my name is William and I'm a student
at Berkeley I'm interested in graph
algorithms and sum of squares
programming
one lessons on I'm a second year PhD
student in TJC I'm currently working on
mostly decremental Gaff algorithms but
I'm happy to learn about any cool new
topics
hi I'm Ishani I'm a PhD student at
Stanford and I'm mainly interested in
graph algorithms and some combinatorial
optimization
hi I'm Zoe I'm a PhD student at Boston
University I'm interested in algorithms
and optimization
hi I'm Chandra chakuri I'm a professor
at the University of Illinois
Urbana-Champaign I'm broadly interested
in algorithms and cognitive optimization
hi everybody I'm Danny doffman I'm PhD
student at Tel Aviv University I'm
interested in graph algorithms currently
a cat algorithms expanding the
composition stuff and also algorithms
for solving a mean payoff games and
energy games and so on
hi everyone I'm Alexander Mayo I'm a
professor at the University of
Massachusetts Amherst
the area is in data management but I've
done some work on diversity in this
election approximation algories
hi everyone I'm Matt Bernard I'm a
backlit product so I did my undergrad
here in math
and I'm interested groups and graphs
perhaps representation Theory and
mathematical physics
hi uh I am Sharon bhattacharya I'm from
University of Warwick in the UK and I'm
interested in Dynamic online sublinear
algorithms and data structures
hi I'm the Malia panigrahi from Duke I'm
interested in broadly in algorithms
specifically in graph algorithms and
very particularly in the minimum cut
problem
everyone I'm David weitz I'm currently
in limbo so unaffiliated I used to be
visiting a scientists at Google up until
a couple weeks ago and I'll be joining
the technion as an assistant professor
uh beginning of next month
I'm broadly interested in graph
algorithms with uh focus on algorithms
that deal with incomplete information
about their data so online algorithms
Dynamic algorithms streaming distributed
algorithms and I'm looking forward to
hearing a lot about uh well what we're
going to be talking about this week
hi everyone my name is Catherine Hanover
I am an assistant professor at
University of Vienna Austria and I'm
interested in well graph algorithms in
theory and practice algorithm
engineering yeah
and and I'll be giving a talk on
Thursday
hi everyone I'm Grandma's goransen
assistant professor at University of
Vienna Austria and I'm interested in
algorithm design
Dynamic algorithms combinator
optimization and yeah
hi uh I'm Bento Natura I'm a postdoc at
Georgia Tech and I'm interested mainly
in all sorts of combinatorial
optimization and convex continuous
optimization
I am actually Robin General I'm a
postdoc at CWI and I'm mostly interested
in continuous optimization and
spectrograph Theory
uh hi everyone I'm roshu I'm from duke I
work on graph algorithms especially I
mean cut related problems
hi everybody my name is Nicole wine I'm
here for the semester before that I was
a postdoc at dymax and before that I was
a PhD student with Virginia Williams at
MIT after this I'm going to go to
University of Michigan as an assistant
professor I'm interested in graph
algorithms Dynamic algorithms also
fine-grained complexity and also with an
emphasis on like shortest path and paths
and structure of shortest paths
I am sarasai
foreign
University State University New York I'm
also part of the logic and algorithm in
database and our program currently with
this my interests are actually
officially programming languages and
compilers but I'm really interested in
algorithms and graph algorithms you can
start with a high-level relations like
in database and generally efficient
implementation in particular more recent
years and distribute algorithms and even
logic languages
hi everyone I'm crime Kaplan from Tel
Aviv University and from Google
I guess I'm interested in a lot of
things mainly data structures and
algorithms
a lot of differential privacy recently
I'm happy to be here and talk to you
I'm Anthony
from Newfoundland
and I'm interested in complexity logic
and theoretical computer science in
general
oh hi I'm Lawrence a PhD student at U of
T University of Toronto I generally work
on spectrograph Theory and continuous
optimization and more recently with a
focus on ipms
hi my name is IBN Zhao and I'm also a
PhD student at the University of Toronto
and I do a spectral grass Theory and
algorithms through those and uh recently
started doing some differential oh sorry
uh starting doing some discrepancy
series stuff
hi I'm Yin Chang I'm a PhD student from
MIT I'm interested in if I'm going
complexity and algorithms
hi everyone I'm Cheyenne I'm a fifth
year PhD student at MIT advised by
Virginia Williams and Ryan Williams
there I really like algebraic methods
and applications and graph algorithms
and also enjoy more generally just
questions related to fine grain
complexity and designing faster graph
algorithms
Ki I go by Cuba I'm a research scientist
at Google I was doing Dynamic graph
algorithms from for my PhD these days
I'm working on running algorithms on
very large graphs both in theory and
practice we we went around on graphs of
up to billions of trillions of edges and
in this Workshop I'm really interested
to to talk about or understand how to
make Dynamic algorithms more practical
foreign
hello uh my name is Matthew I'm a third
year undergraduate uh here at UC
Berkeley
um recently I worked on minimum cut with
the Jason and also uh streaming minimum
cut with uh Jelani and David and I am
here because I am interested in working
on new things
hi I am Virginia vasilevska Williams I'm
a professor at MIT I'm interested in
graph and Matrix algorithms and fine
grain complexity and more generally
theoretical computer science it's so
General that I'm a co-organizer of the
other program and a long-term visitor of
this one
okay
hi I'm guy blowock I do parallel and
current data structures and algorithms I
do a bit of both theory and practice and
recently I've been doing a lot of work
on batch Dynamic algorithms and
concurrent graph algorithms
all right so uh we're still done early
so we we have 28 minutes until the next
session so I suggest that everyone take
a break
come back at 10 30.
foreign